le soir à annecy arcadion
c'est le printemps
[Rires]
il ya un truc qui va pas avec mes yeux
la en
j'arrive pas à les détacher de toi
on dit souvent que la place des femmes
c'est dans la cuisine franchement je
trouve ça déplacé parce que ta place à
toi aller dans mon coeur
je
sais que tu as pris du poids en ce
moment est mais c'est pas grave parce
que pour moi ça fait toujours plus de
toit
[Musique]
no spam
scarlett
en fait j'ai connecté le miroir donc je
voulais te montrer tu vois là exemple tu
peux mettre la musique fait que la
mettre en pause tu peux passer la
prochaine mais note qu'il arrête mais il
ya aussi une reconnaissance faciale donc
si je fais ça je reconnais mon visage tu
as essayé
ohlala arrivez vous à vivre au quotidien
avec ce visage tu m'enlèves tout ça tu
m'enlèves des objets connectés j'en veux
plus tu me lis
des cheveux
quand même
famille
white
comment réagir en présence d'une
personne vraiment attractive regardez la
regarder en bas rester un deux trois le
vais doucement le regard regarder
ailleurs sourire léger gratter vaut le
coup les chez vous les lèvres
regardez-la fait un clin d'oeil puis
avec l'autre oeil avec les deux yeux
regarder avec les yeux doux sortez le
bout de votre langue aval est vraiment
très fort respirez très fort regardez la
mort dès le bout de votre doigt mort dès
le milieu de votre doigt